bienvenidos a nuevo primeramente quiero
pedirte una disculpa pues el vídeo
pasado fue un vídeo muy largo y tal vez
lo puede haber dividido en dos vídeos
sin embargo yo prefiero terminar un
problema y que tú entiendas bien la
solución de ese problema a dividir el
problema en dos vídeos porque cuando yo
tengo un problema que estoy dividiéndolo
en dos vídeos muchas veces la solución
te puede parecer un poco confusa o tal
vez no tan fácil de resolver así que por
eso decidí hacer un vídeo un poco más
largo en el último vídeo pero con la
idea de terminar el problema número 12 y
a continuación vamos ser el problema
número 13 así que manos a la obra ya
falta poco para acabar este examen
número 4 tanto el examen como la sección
así que vayamos al problema número 13 y
el problema número 13 tiene una gráfica
así que pues vamos a hacerla tengo una
gráfica parecida a ésta venga aquí esta
va a ser me dije de ayer por acá tengo
mi eje x muy bien
voy a poner que este es mi game
por acá tengo a mi eje x y después tengo
una gráfica
llena de rectas así que primero vamos a
poner las escalas por aquí voy a decir
que este es el valor de 2 este es el
valor de 2 por acá tengo el valor de 4
por acá el 6 por acá está el 8 y por acá
está el 10 mientras que de esta parte
por aquí tengo el 2 por acá tengo el 4
por acá tengo el 6 por acá tengo el 8 y
por acá voy a decir que tengo el 10
perfecto y después la gráfica de esta
función de x se ve como varios segmentos
de rectas hundidas en ciertos puntos
específicos fíjate bien primeramente
empieza el cerca del punto 1 717 estamos
más o menos parados como por aquí y
después tengo una recta que baja hasta
el 4,2 es muy parecido a esto
va a bajar hasta este punto tengo una
recta kim ok y después mi función sube
del 42 al 63 más o menos del 42 al 63 am
se ve más o menos así ok y una vez que
estamos en el 63 vamos a subir hasta el
8,8 subimos bastante hasta el 88 que es
más o menos como por aquí 8,8 a algo más
o menos así ok por aquí y después de
aquí parece ser que toca al 10 en el
valor de 3 es más o menos como por aquí
es una gráfica parecida está ok y qué es
lo que me preguntan me dicen si g de 2
sigue de 2 o no dejen que enviar la
herramienta sigue de 2
de 2 esto es igual acá entonces lo que
me preguntan es cuánto vale g beckham y
bueno pues este es un problema realmente
de mucha intuición intuición intuición
intuición intuición porque solamente
tenemos valores aproximados y lo
importante es fijarse en un aproximado a
donde llegamos si fue de 2 es igual a
camps
entonces cuando x vale 2 por cierto esta
es la gráfica gtx gdx ok
cuando x vale 2 gdx valer veamos
vamos a puntear esto puntear puntear
puntear puntear puntear puntilla de
puntilla de puntear llegamos justo como
por aquí y si nosotros nos fijamos en
este valor en james es decir la altura
en ye pues vamos a llegar a un valor
cercano al 5 es decir la mitad de entre
6 y 4 por lo tanto yo puedo decir que
aproximadamente y bueno aproximadamente
porque la gráfica no me está dando
valores exactos aproximadamente
5 este valor que tengo aquí y bueno
entonces aproximadamente podemos
concluir que g de 2 es igual a camps que
esto a su vez es igual o es
aproximadamente igual a 5 más o menos
eso es lo que nos dice esta gráfica yo
supongo que si en efecto es el valor de
5 entonces que de 2 es igual al valor de
5 ok y entonces sigue de 2 es igual a
camps y k es igual a 5 entonces lo que
me preguntan o lo que quiero saber en
este problema es cuánto vale g de camps
pero héte que es lo mismo que g de 5 yo
lo que quiero saber es cuánto vale g de
5 esta va a ser la respuesta en el
problema y pues vamos a fijarnos aquí
tengo el 2x de 94 por aquí por aquí
tengo al 5
este es el 5 en x y entonces lo que
quiero saber es la altura que va a
alcanzar en la gráfica gtx y para esto
vamos a hacer la línea punteada punteada
punteada volteada por acá vamos a poner
puntitos hasta llegar a este valor justo
a este valor
me voy a acercar al eje de las 10 para
ver cuánto vale que de 5 entonces vamos
a ver qué altura me voy a tomar voy a ir
por aquí por aquí por aquí y por aquí
por aquí y por aquí y por aquí más o
menos por acá voy bajando y bajando y
llegó a este valor de aquí ok
más o menos esto es lo que vale g de 5
ahora si te das cuenta cuando empecé el
vídeo yo te dije que g de 6 am o más
bien que estábamos en el punto 6 3
así que si esta función está bajando a
75 tiene que ser menor que 3 voy a
suponer que es a entre 3 y 2.5 y lo voy
a poner para quitarnos de problemas 2.5
2.5 de hecho si yo quisiera pensar que
el gt5 es igual a 3 esto no puede ser
porque en mis respuestas no está es por
eso que es muy necesaria la intuición
para resolver problemas de ese arte en
mis respuestas no está 3 sin embargo sí
está 2.5 y bueno usando esta misma
lógica te das cuenta que tiene que ser
un valor menor que 3 porque traes hasta
más
como por aquí este es el valor de 3
entonces es un número menor que 3 y
mayor que 2
creo que 2.5 es una buena opción
entonces la respuesta sería el inciso b
el inciso b que dice 2.5 2.5 y esta es
la respuesta de este problema lo único
que tuvimos que hacer es incluir un poco
los valores para ge de 2 y paraje de 5 y
tomarnos una aproximación de qué es lo
que estaba pasando con esta gráfica gtx
que tengo aquí muy bien pues vamos a
volver la pantalla y vámonos al
siguiente problema el problema número 14
el problema número 14 que me dice lo
siguiente si 01 es menor o igual que
equis y esto a su vez es menor o igual
que 8 y por otra parte menos 1 es menor
o igual que ya que a su vez es menor o
igual que 3 entonces cuál es el conjunto
que representa todos los posibles
valores de x por quién
x x cuál es el conjunto que representa
todos los posibles valores de x por
james y bueno lo que se me ocurre es
fijarnos en los extremos vamos a
fijarnos en las fronteras de estos
intervalos vamos a agarrarnos los puntos
extremos lo más que pueda valer xy james
para ver cuánto va al día x por james
entonces x x va de 0 a 8 déjame ponerlo
así el valor más pequeño que puede tomar
x es 0 y el valor más grande que puede
tomar xs8 ok mientras por otra parte
james el valor más pequeño que puede
tomar es menos 1 y el valor más grande
que puede tomar estrés por lo tanto
vamos a ver qué me queda si yo
multiplico los valores extremos de x y
de james para así obtener a x por james
fíjate bien si nos fijamos en x por
james que es lo que podría pasar con x
porque bueno podría quedarnos a menos
uno por cero pero menos uno por cero
pues debemos tener también 3 por 0 pero
3 por 0 también es cero entonces
seguimos quedándonos en el mismo punto
pero también podríamos tener 8 x menos
18 permanece 1 es menos 8 menos 8 es un
valor mucho más chico que 0 entonces
aquí está el menos ocho ok podemos tomar
termina el valor de 0 y 8 por 3 es 24
cuando los dos son positivos y toman el
valor máximo pues es precisamente el
valor máximo que puede tomar x porque x
porque es 24 ok esto quiere decir que si
nosotros nos fijamos en x por james
entonces x x ya está acotado entre a
menos 8 entre menos 8 y 24 y 24 y 24
dicho de otra manera los valores que
puede tomar x por jeff dada estas
desigualdades que tenemos aquí arriba
están entre menos 8 y 24 y bueno 24 es
un número que sale de una manera muy
intuitiva tú dices 8 x 33 24
el valor máximo que puede tomar x por
james sin embargo ten cuidado con el
menos 8 tal vez como obtuvimos el menos
8 no sea lo más intuitivo del mundo no
sea tan fácil de visualizar pero lo
único que hice fue fijarme en los
valores extremos y multiplicar todas las
posibles combinaciones de los valores
más grandes y más pequeños que podría
tomar export yema y me di cuenta que 0 x
menos 100 x 30 pero como este es menos 1
y aquí puedo tomar un valor positivo
entonces cuando yo multiplique 8 x menos
uno puede obtener un valor menor que
cero es decir menos 8 y me di cuenta que
menos 8 es el valor más pequeño que
puede tomar x por james por lo tanto ya
está mi respuesta es esta de aquí que
por cierto es el inciso en el inciso me
dice justo esto menos 8 es menor o igual
que x por james que a su vez es menor o
igual que 24 muy bien problema número 14
pues vamos a resolver el problema número
borremos la pantalla y vamos a hacer el
problema número 15 el problema número 15
y tiene la figura siguiente así que
déjame ver si me sale tengo una recta
por aquí
ok tengo como un mano tengo una recta
por la cam una recta por la cara aunque
una vez topo la está muy bien y me dan y
solamente me dan un dato me dicen que
este vale n o no dejen cambiar de
herramienta me dicen que este ángulo
vale n ok y lo que me preguntan lo que
quien sabe en este problema es cuánto
vale la suma de estos ángulos déjame
ponerlo con un color llamativo cuánto
vale la suma de este ángulo y se va a
confundir con n más ver mejor este este
ángulo más este ángulo más este ángulo
más este ángulo cuánto vale la suma de
estos cuatro ángulos en términos de m
ok perfecto esto parece el juego de los
ángulos así que vamos a ver si este vale
en este también vale n porque son
ángulos opuestos por el vértice
entonces esto también vale n ok estos
dos valen n y ahora que podemos saber
bueno lo que puedo decir es que este
ángulo de aquí este de aquí vale 180
menos de 180 menos n porque estos dos
son ángulos suplementarios como están
sobre la misma recta entonces este más
este deben de sumar 180 o dicho otra
manera este debe de valer 180 menos n
lo que le falta a n para llegar a ser
180 y de igual manera este este vale
también 180 menos en 180 menos en ok ya
tengo el valor de todos los cuatro
ángulos que tengo aquí pero como saco el
valor de la suma de estos otros cuatro
ángulos
pues bien fija menos primero en este
triángulo de aquí en este triángulo de
aquí ok vamos a verlo bien si este
ángulo se llama a y este ángulo se llama
be
entonces qué sabemos de la suma de estos
tres ángulos bueno que me tienen que dar
180 grados o dicho otra manera
ver más este ángulo de aquí que valen
180 menos n
esto tiene que ser igual a 180 grados ok
o dicho de otra manera de aquí podemos
despejar a la suma de armas bien es
decir que a más bien es igual a 180
menos a 180 menos n o dicho de otra
manera jamás ven es lo mismo que 180
menos 180 más en éste y éstas se van me
queda que más ven es simple y
sencillamente n wow esto está padrísimo
la suma de estos dos me da m
y si nos fijamos en estos dos bueno pues
de manera análoga vamos a llegar a que
la suma de estos dos también s n mã
inclusive si quieres también podemos
ponerle el nombre si éste vale de y éste
vale
entonces sabemos que d
más el otro ángulo más este de aquí más
180 cn esto tiene que ser igual a 180
grados y de aquí puedo cancelar este con
este y me va a quedar que de más y esto
es igual a n ok y si yo lo que quiero
saber es cuánto vale la suma de además
de más en la suma de a más b
más de más y pues esto es lo mismo que n
de estos dos y n de estos dos más
n o dicho otra manera la suma de estos
cuatro es igual a 2 n ok y esta es la
respuesta de este problema que por
cierto es el inciso b ya está y bueno
creo que ya no tengo tiempo de hacer el
último problema de esta sección así que
vamos a dejarlo para el siguiente vídeo
no te pierdas el siguiente vídeo en
donde vamos a ver el último problema de
este examen 4 y de esta sección número 8
hasta la próxima